The Joe Rogan experience.
That's an interesting thing for someone
who studies artificial intelligence.
I mean if anybody listen to this podcast,
like what the fuck did I do?
So many reservoir dogs, they talk
about movies. So many people.
And you're talking about autonomous
vehicles. We have plenty of time, sir.
We have plenty of time. But that's the
beautiful thing about this podcast.
We're just talking. So tell me what
you got here with your notes man.
I mean you are fucking prepared. I
mean you have a lot of shit here. Many,
many pages for sure. I don't want to
miss out on this stuff. I mean there's a,
there's been a lot of exciting stuff on
the autonomous vehicle space since you
came on.
I got a Tesla and I've experienced with
that thing is like when I put it on
autopilot and it's stunning. Yeah, crazy.
I mean this is the performance
of the v amazing well in,
in terms of its ability to change lanes
and its ability to drive without you
doing anything.
I just put my hand on the wheel and
hold it there and it does all the work.
So because like one or two
people listen to this podcast,
I want to take this opportunity and
tell people, if you drive a Tesla,
whether you listen to this now or a
year from now, two years from now,
Tesla or any other car,
keep your damn eyes on the road.
So whatever you think
the system is able to do,
you will have to still monitor the road
and you still have to take over when it
fails,
if when really.
So
we're throwing,
this is like the moment we're
throwing down right now.
I think it's an your level of
expertise obviously. I mean,
I'm not throwing down with you on that.
No, I think it's really important to,
in this transitionary phase,
whatever the car company, uh,
whatever the system that we
don't overtrust a system,
we don't become complacent.
We don't think he could do
more than they can. Currently.
40,000 people die in the United
States from, from fatal crashes.
The number one reason for that is
distraction. So texting smart phones,
how much has it gone up since smart
phones, people don't, exactly,
they're trying to understand that.
There's a lot of studies showing
that it's significant increases,
but it's hard to say it's because of
smartphones, but it's almost obvious.
It's pretty obvious.
The,
the flip side is even though
everybody's not using a smart phone,
texting and so on, they've become
better at using the smartphone.
So they're better at texting and
driving the better balancing that.
Now this is a horrible thing to do.
So if you're listening to this podcast,
you should,
uh,
listen to it in your car and keep
your eyes on the road and not text.
I think worst was Pokemon
when Pokemon was in its prime.
I was watching a guy on the highway
playing Pokemon as he was driving.
No more than one person.
Two people, a guy.
And I saw a girl do it once to holding
the phone on the steering wheel.
Playing Pokemon. Yeah. Yeah. It's
incredible. What are you doing Jamie?
That's GRANDPA's. Oh Shit. Sorry.
I'm confused. What does this,
uh, this grandpa in Japan,
he drives around on a bike.
Oh, my phones playing
Pokemon all at the same time.
This guy is 15 phones. It's ridiculous.
This guy needs to find hookers.
There's people that do this also in
their car with maybe four or five doing
exactly what you're saying. This man needs
a better hobby. This is preposterous.
He can't see what the fuck's
going on in front of him.
He spends about $300 a month to
buy virtual currencies in the game.
Wow. That guy's board or
in an innovative genius,
depending on the perspective.
One eye,
people misuse their
innovative Josie innovative.
He's just playing a stupid game while
he's driving around on his bike like an
asshole. Well, he's doing in fact
instead set of a woman thing.
It's passion. It's the most amazing
moment of his life playing Pokemon.
I'm sure most people are on my side.
Sensible woman versus do you think
most people are on your side?
They think Sonneville woman's the
greatest movie, all that to a woman,
but I was defending
godfather sent to a woman.
You weren't defending
godfather against me. I mean,
I'm going to throw you under the band.
Okay.
I'm going to manipulate this conversation.
Jamie, can you edit this in post?
Did you see the video that just came
out yesterday of a Tesla on autopilot?
Avoiding a crash. All right, so yeah,
I have and there's a lot of exams.
Quite a few of those. Yeah, of course.
It's like hard to prove exactly what
happened and where the auto Paul was
involved.
Just like on the flip side,
it's hard to prove that autopilot
was involved in the dangerous stuff.
But I think by any measure,
the media is really negative in terms
of their reporting on tests that there,
I think,
I think you've talked to this about
before in general and negativity gets more
clicks,
right?
And I think Tesla negative stuff
on Tesla gets a lot of clicks,
so,
well not Tesla.
Let me speak more broadly about autonomous
vehicles. If there's any fatality,
any crash, it's overrepresented.
It's over reported on.
So I need to meet people
who are interested in AI
helping save lives in these
systems like autopilot.
I feel you carry the responsibility of
being at least as good at as a driver.
You are. I want it under manual
control. So don't text and drive.
Keep your eyes on the road.
If I say anything over and over on this
podcast is that drunk driving, of course,
is the other one,
and so don't drink and drive,
but the number one thing
is distracted driving.